orphan burns hoping to get some run
support rock but just keep doing his
thing on the mount yeah
last time out against kansas city and no
decision two hits two runs allowed one
walk nine strikeouts
for corbin his last timeout six innings
of work in that start
profile took the tall third strike
first strikeout of the night for corbin
burns and backdoor cutter 94
right on the outside corner
making his tenth start to padres uniform
is joe muscaro no no joe and he was very
good his last outing but against the
milwaukee brewers april 19th
he spun a gem even throwing out 13
strikeouts that night
and that is strike three came back
nicely done as he strikes out wong wins
the battle
you can see by the swings that he was
getting early on
that it was going to be one of those
days for him three and two vogelback
swings and misses strike three nasty
slider came back with it back-to-back
case for musgrove to start the game
garcia second base for omar narvaez this
one
fouled over by third base and hassan kim
made the
catch just beyond the dugout and by the
screen hassan kim comes up with it on
the backhand what a catch
two away runners on the corners for
jerickson profile
o2 pitch runner goes again and the pitch
is outside thrown down to second and
breaking for home is carratini he will
score
in the back door now taken third is kim
how about that
the catcher narvaez decides to throw on
the stolen base by kim at second base
and as soon as he does carratini takes
off plate word and the padres score a
run they force a run
a ball in two strikes to jerks and
profile burns now set and ready here's
the pitch and profar swings and lines it
through the right side a base hit and a
run
two to nothing san diego on jericks and
profar's rbi single with two outs to
bring home hassan campbell thomas played
every day since the trade and goes
chasing after that slider and strikes
out four strikeouts for joe musgrove one
down in the third inning
two in the first one in the second and
he starts the third with a strikeout of
adamus
in there for strike three three straight
strikeouts for joe musgrove
one-two pitch
swinging and a miss
good off speed from corbin burns
[Applause]
strikeout number four for corbin the
crews have been able to handle tattees
fairly well so far in this series after
coming off the injured list and being
red red hot
good breaking pitch got him out in front
big swing
he has that large pitch selection but
it's by design and he won't go to all of
those pitches necessarily two on pitch
sharply hit ground ball deep in the hole
at second fielded by wong spins and
throws from the right field grass and he
gets osmer what a play by the gold
glover colton wong
display of range and balance
and arm strength all in the same play
from colton wong
made it look rather easy actually he is
over 11 against the brewers this season
struck him out make it over 12 against
the crew three up and three down inning
for corbin burns yeah because you're
crawling you're you know it's kind of a
struggle yeah
swing and a miss at an elevated fastball
and musgrove with strikeout number six
one away in the bottom of the fifth
inning
joe just overpowering narvaez you
mentioned it earlier i mean he looks
like he has
that kind of stuff again
breaking ball has been good he elevates
here back to full here's musgrove
ground ball up the middle base hit
brewers have their first knock
kane content with the single
see if that ignites the offense for the
brewers on a breaking ball what's new
another slider
from joe musgrove
and see lorenzo happy to get the base
hit
[Applause]
and he walked him on four straight to
load the bases
and jace tingler is wasting no time
[Applause]
he's coming out
and he's going to bring in the
left-hander tim hill
tim hill
he's allowed earned runs in just three
of his 21 outings
on the ground to short
tatis will flip to second for the fourth
shot that ends the inning and tim hill
gets out of the jam the brewers leave
them loaded it's two nothing san diego
fam goes
and dropping the baseball is narvaez
stolen base for tommy pham
more running for the padres
2-0 pitch to profar
show it but again and gets by narvaez
and the third base
is tommy pham
second and third one out and fernando
tatis junior coming up he's grounded out
to second and struck out swinging so far
against burns oh for two like this is a
big risk for craig counsel i wonder if
they'll throw him
like he has two strikes already
in the air to center field where lorenzo
kane
will make the catch tagging at third
bases fam throw goes to third and the
padres take a three-nothing lead a sac
fly for fernando tati's junior with two
outs and runners in scoring position
this season eric hosmer is hitting 433
that is the case right now with pro far
at second base and two down and a ground
ball sharply hit up the middle and into
center field for a base hit pro four
rounding third on his way home rbi
single eric hosmer four nothing padres
in the sixth ho-hum for eric hosmer
something we've seen him do all season
long jesse just gave you the numbers
with two outs runners in scoring
position
a little cutter
in on the hands
eric just hits this ball right back up
the middle
second and third one out
and fan will chop one up the middle up
the glove of the pitcher runs scores
throw to first and they are able to get
tommy pham
[Applause]
run in and the padres take a five
nothing lead
line to right field and that's a fair
ball headed down to the right field
corner
it'll score o'grady with the sixth
padres run
it is an rbi double and the padres lead
it six to nothing
second hit second rbi of the night for
jerks and profar
3-2 high fly deep right field travis
shaw
has gandhi
first time since may first
for travis shaw so much for the
scoreless streak for craig stamin
[Applause]
travis shaw puts an end to that gets the
brewers on the board
long and bad for travis shaw
they will get a hold of a fastball on
the inside corner
down and it gets away from narvaez and
here comes tatis to score
and the padres take a 7-1 lead
musgrove had six in his four and
two-thirds innings
didn't allow a run and only one hit
garbage grounds one right side
and it's tatis to first base for the out
that ends the ball game